brasil se convirtió en el primer país de
la región y el segundo en todo el mundo
en superar los 400.000 muertos por la
pandemia los expertos atribuyeron la
situación al fracaso del gobierno para
imponer restricciones combinado con un
lento proceso de vacunación y el
surgimiento de variantes más contagiosas
del virus todo todo esto contribuye al
agravamiento del escenario porque cuando
rompes las medidas no farmacológicas
cuando no las sigues que vas a tener una
circulación intensa de personas
aumentando el riesgo de más variantes
series de las que ya están circulando
predominantemente en los jóvenes ya que
la población anciana ha sido inmunizada
con al menos una dosis lista el
constante aumento en el número de
contagios en argentina- hizo que este
domingo alcanzará los 3 millones es el
segundo país de latinoamérica en llegar
a esta cifra el personal médico dice que
los hospitales se están colapsando el
gobierno argentino extendió durante tres
semanas más las medidas destinadas a
frenar el avance del virus entre ellas
un toque de queda a partir de las 8 de
la noche pero para los expertos esto no
es suficiente
ninguna medida nosotros vamos a poder
vamos a seguir extendiendo las medidas
acá aquí sería de acá hasta dentro de
dos años si no hacemos lo que hay que
hacer que es testear y vacunar colombia
cerró una semana en la que las muertes
alcanzaron niveles récord con más de 400
diarias varias ciudades del país han
impuesto confinamientos estrictos
durante los fines de semana y la
ocupación de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos en la capital llega al 91% la
organización panamericana de la salud
mostró preocupación por suramérica donde
describió la situación como compleja e
instó a los países con excedentes de
vacunas a considerar donar una parte
importante de sus suministros a las
américas